David Tepper Howard Marks Mike no
regrets Gary Cohn even Jamie Dimon told
me his number one pick Duke I'm not sure
he was doing the math of bracketology
two of his three kids went to Duke so
that's why he loves them but let's go to
David to prefer see big Florida Arizona
Louisville Virginia I'm gonna say kind
of obvious pics but tell me make all the
favorites right don't call it obvious
call it the most straightforward the
most conservative if you think about
investments as how volatile do you want
to be he went with the least volatile
strategy that's highest expected that's
nice so from the perspective of a sports
fan no all due respect to David Tepper
no offense intended that's kind of lame
it was the highest probability picks for
those four teams but it may even have
some heart or gonna have some heart
involved doesn't have enough risk maybe
as some of the other guys do all right
who's got some risk cuz I'm looking at
Howard Marks Florida Wisconsin Michigan
I mean ever he has less risk although
here's what Utah State everyone on our
list has Florida we're not seeing too
many people with Roose concen what do
you think it's interesting so look at
he's got a one A one A two and A four
and if you look historically that is the
lineup that's most likely represented in
the final four so he has the right
balance between conservative with the
ones and then a little bit of risk with
the twos in the force we had a great
story on wichita state and how difficult
their road to the Final Four is going to
be I think even Charles Barkley is
quoted in the story saying you know what
the NCAA has done is they've made it
really difficult for Wichita State to
get there because they have three out of
the top four three out of last year's
final four teams are playing against
them but based on the math they have a
lower chance of winning their region
that Louisville does and Louisville
seated for there you go deeva I know an
ultimate Wichita State in there do you
have them in yours I don't have them in
mind I think Louisville's got a better
chance in wichita state does from my
over though Louisville some people are
saying they got a poor seed they
shouldn't have been seated number for
Howard Marks has them in there do you
think they could get knocked out because
they're gonna obviously have to play
tougher the lower seed does it make it
that much harder because the teams that
they're playing are still going to be
pretty weak and in fact it makes them an
undervalued pick if we look at all these
guys only two of them have Louisville
but they all have Florida and that's
what you always see the favorite team
gets over picked they have picked a
hundred percent everyone's picked them
in their brackets
well I really get it right for all get
it wrong so there's no variance among
these guys no one's gonna win because of
Florida don't you have an advantage on
Louisville if you get them Marc Lasry
he's got do cuz I said Jamie Dimon
didn't do all four but he picked you is
that an emotional pick because so many
people love the school me just yesterday
they got shellacked by UVA well he's got
dukan that's not bad it's the North
Carolina pick that's where he's taking a
lot of risk cuz that's a six seed he's
the only guy in this whole group that
took anyone outside the top four and you
can see these are portfolio managers
right they are picking strong portfolios
and there's only one guy who's taking
one team out of the top side you gotta
check in with Eric and two weeks then
you have looked across the board at
these guys pics who do you think is
gonna win it out of all of them I think
it'll be marks cone or Einhorn they have
the right portfolios all right Gary Cohn
Howard Marks David Einhorn our own
in-house expert Erik Jimmy thinks you're
gonna take win these brackets what do
you think i will check in with Eric
every day every actually throughout the
tournament so I'm gonna hang out with
him by the water cooler and see what's
going I wonder about the probability of
if you pick all number ones that's not
gonna work that never happened
conservative it happened once but it's
weights you can so it has happened
that's what I was wondering